Lexi I told you about this you are
detained you are not free to leave at
this point do you understand that yes
sir how big is it it's full term what
um so I started working her up
um we did a pregnancy test on it showed
positive it's usually nine because she
had sex
um then she said she had to go to the
bathroom she went to the bathroom she
was in there for quite a while we kept
knocking on the door finally we got her
to open the door and there was Bloody
everywhere she was cleaning it up so we
took her back to the room and I was
afraid that she knew she was pregnant
she had done something to herself
um so the doctor started exam on her we
had the lady come to clean the bathroom
she put the baby in the trash can and
then she put another clean liner over
the top of it oh wow okay so they looked
when they looked in there it looked
there was no trash in there but it was
underneath the clean bag the baby's dead
okay we have him in Toronto too but
she killed the kid yeah yeah how old was
the how old was to be I don't know it's
full term
she just had it she had it in the
bathroom was what happened and then she
whatever she did I don't know she's
gonna lie she wouldn't tell us she's
pregnant she's been lying the whole time
okay so that's what's going on
um I just pulled the doctor out of the
room so nothing's been said to the
patient or the mother that's in there
yet okay um I have Leela the housekeeper
if you want to interview her yeah she's
doing it kind of found underneath I
wanted to get with you guys first and
then get with her to get her statement
before I even did anything well I'm the
charge and this is what has happened
okay you can interview the nurse that
had her okay the two nurses that were
taking care of her you can talk to the
tech which is Lori she's the one that
went in there and actually found it
because legal's like this is really
heavy okay so when uh Lori went in there
and of course the baby was underneath
the cleanliner okay yeah we can if we
can speak with Lori for that okay
so officers know he's the first thing
though is I need to make sure that the
mother the woman who deliver the baby is
betterly stable
um I don't know if she delivered at
placenta she's bleeding a lot I just got
her accepted to Loveless so I need to
get her up there as soon as possible
I'm sorry
we discovered a dead baby in the
bathroom oh my gosh
sorry
he came out
Lexi I told you about this
if I just asked you Bailey to tell me
the troubles
it was not crying or maybe
what did you do to it okay stop right
here
number one priority guys number one
priority is she just had a baby I don't
know if she's delivered the placenta
she's bleeding significantly yeah I've
spoken to the obstetrician at Loveless
they want her up there as soon as
possible okay I need your I just need
your permission to transfer her medical
she's 19. oh you're right but she is a
student too
you're right she used it I'm sorry I
forgot
but you need to for to make sure that
you're safe I need to send you to love
list to labor delivery
will you please agree to that yeah
yes I yes
um in terms I'm sorry about this but in
terms of delivering
um a baby and it looked like you tried
to hide it we do have to have the police
involved
and nothing was crying it came out with
nothing I know I know but the baby's
gonna have to be taken for autopsy and
investigator and everything
I'm sorry
I'm so sorry that we need to do this
correctly
um and I want to be transparent with you
about what our steps are going to be
officer do you need to do you guys need
to talk to her before we get her
transferred
um
do you think 20 30 minutes yeah
hopefully yes okay
they're going to be talking first okay
do you guys have undercharged Nursery do
you guys have any questions for me like
how big is it it's full term
nine months nothing was crying
let's see have you watched the news of
being the girls that what they do to
their babies and what they go to jail
crying
and it's three any other questions
okay
all right so as of right now like I'm
gonna say this we're gonna have the
detectives come over here and they're
going to talk to you okay we have to
gather some more information about
what's kind of what's going on go get
your statement they're going to get the
doctor statements they're going to get
everybody's statements okay
so
I don't know everything yet okay so I'm
not going to tell you
I can't tell you nothing honestly okay
no well right now she's being detained
so she's not gonna leave from here at
all period okay so one of us will be in
your custody right yeah
yeah she's not under arrest but she is
detained okay she's not free to leave
so while this whole thing is coming up
is you're not free to leave okay one of
us will be in here the whole time with
you because you're not going to try to
leave or nothing like that sure
the detectives will be here they're
going to talk to you I mean your cares
of the utmost right now okay they're
gonna do what they need to do to take
care of you to make sure you get stable
they get you transferred out or whatever
like I said the detectives already been
notified they're already on the way so
they're going to come talk to you all
right so don't leave don't try to do
nothing one of us is always going to be
in here in this room with you okay
unless we have to step out for doctor's
order or something like that because if
you need to examine you or do something
with you but other than that like I said
you are detained you are not free to
leave at this point do you understand
that
yes okay
where was Arabia
I don't know I have no clue yet like I
said I just talked to the charge nurse
we're still getting all the information
right now okay
um once we get that information like I
said the detectives they can clue you
out on everything and talk to you more
about it okay all right
oh do you happen to have an idea
foreign
[Applause]
I'll be back
um
could you do me a favor run these two
um to the record call
okay it'll be uh New Mexico DL both of
them whenever you're ready
where did you put the baby at
all right
you put it in the back yes yeah
why did you say anything to us
do you want to get in trouble for this
now yeah
all right just give it a shot okay
nobody speaking detectives whenever
she's ready okay
you ready for the second one
all right last time you have that second
one
all right
[Laughter]
awesome thank you so much
foreign
be back in here okay if you need
something we're not going to stay in
here okay
so what we're going to do is we're going
to stay on the outside of the door okay
as long as you promise me you're not you
know you're not going to hurt yourself
okay like I said I
I this is a lot I know it is okay you're
young
you know
I don't want to be in here kind of
adding to to your anxiety and everything
else okay
if you need something just push that
button okay and then they'll come in
there they're on their way okay
okay so as soon as I get here they're
gonna talk to you I mean the reason why
your mom well not yet yeah
once they get here then it's up to them
if they're okay with her coming back
here then
the reason why is because you're an
adult you're 19 years old if you're a
juvenile shoot
okay
if you have any questions yeah
beside here
and
this is for the fight crew it's going to
transfer you to episode
27th
they'll be here for 30 minutes
well they're gonna transfer her in 30
minutes okay I'll let him know okay
thank you okay we're gonna be out there
out there tonight
oh I've talked to her about that we just
told her that she can't I got you
nothing back okay once she gets
taken or whatever okay yeah yeah
[Music]
that's when they started working I think
so I got the bathroom
um closed off and then I got the trauma
room closed off because they the trauma
room the housekeeper went in there
because they called it opened it out so
obviously before I should check the
trash can she cleaned everything up once
you do everything in the trash can feel
it was Heavy put it down and she looked
in there and she saw me I know yeah so
then they took the obviously the baby in
the trash can
baby on the table and then that's when
everything is
awesome
we'll see if she was cleaning it up
first because so she was in bed she said
she didn't actually we were here because
one of our other guys
check on her
baby was oh yeah yeah
like I said she the housekeeps were
cleaned up before and everything first
and then when she put all her stuff just
put all the stuff into the trash can
that's what she felt that heavy it was
and she lived in terms
I said you're looking for someone to
talk to your mom
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
thank you
this technology
but then the the Jacks are sweet I had
to drive down the street the Jack's
Frozen up because they couldn't put them
in
oh yeah
[Music]
good
okay Alexi so you're getting obviously
you're getting transported okay so
you're not detained no more the
detectives will be contacting me okay so
if I get a hold of you so
[Music]
much
okay give me a good a good phone number
for you cell phone number
okay
your current street address
all right they'll be in contact with you
okay
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
a bunch of people going all the way in
see once you get this thing started
called
um